bonsoir des vikings merci d'être avec
nous on l'a vu dans ce sujet ces émeutes
au lendemain de la sphère floyd au
printemps dernier et puis plus récemment
les émeutes à philadelphie également la
question raciale at elle vraiment pesé
va-t-elle vraiment pesé dans le résultat
futur de cette élection selon vous des
vikings ya ya cette catégorie cela a
favorisé dans cette élection c'est
certain avec bien sûr la copie 19 et les
soulèvements dans le pays je pense que
ce seront les sujets principaux et les
sujets dont sur lesquels les candidats
vont s'exprimer ce sera un sujet très
important
aujourd'hui plus que jamais l'amérique
semble diviser notamment sur ces
questions on assiste est vraiment à
l'émergence de deux camps notamment au
lendemain de la sphère giorgio floride
moi je peux tout à fait je ne sais pas
si je vous restiez mais en tout cas fait
que tim est né à la faire georges flight
à minneapolis a causé des insurrections
partout dans le pays et même dans le
monde comme en france
et pourtant d'un que nous soyons son
centre de cela très peu de changements
et je ne pensais pas
verrons à l'avenir beaucoup de
changements en fonction de la personne
et les jambes
la présidence de naître un peu éteint
une terrible et prend un avantage de la
situation et joe biden a une longue
histoire de racisme
il a été appliqué les politiques qui ont
mené à l'incarcération de masse
lorsqu'il était haut c'est là avec cette
loi sur les crimes et la criminalité
avant d'avoir un changement concret dans
la rue une modification des politiques
de la police nous allons encore beaucoup
de ces cas et beaucoup de personnes ont
été tuées effectivement depuis la mort
de georges frêche est la préoccupation
reste la même et restera même après les
élections
making nous dit quel que soit finalement
le le candidat il n'y aura pas de
changement dans même temps vous semblez
dire que donald trump a peut-être
exacerbé ces tensions
ça veut dire quoi finalement que
président américain n'a pas une grande
de même source marge de manoeuvre sur
ces questions raciale selon vous ça se
fait plus haut niveau à l'échelle locale
y associe actions effectivement pour moi
l'action devra se faire au niveau local
surtout la police aux états unis et d'un
problème local bien plus que fédérer les
forces de police ont contrôlé au niveau
local et un style que ils sont hors de
contrôle en fait ils sont contrôlés par
des forces encore plus puissante et vu
par le beaucoup de changement radical de
des financements de la police mais on
n'a pas l'impression qu'ils soient prêts
à faire ce genre de choses sans une
pression publique continue c'est la
pression du public qui est les
insurrections qui ont attiré l'attention
sur ce sujet parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup
d'autres tueries beaucoup d'autres morts
et chaque fois le conseil municipal le
maire dise quelques belles paroles et
ensuite on en revient au status quo
[Musique]
c'est très confortable c'est très
bénéfique pour certaines personnes et le
statut cours restera tel qu'il est
jusqu'à ce qu' il y ait un changement
forcé concernant les émeutes de
philadelphie après la mort d'un jeune
afro américain de 27 ans il y a quelques
jours donald trump a déclaré que c'était
en quelque sorte la ford la fonte des
élus démocrates locaux la faute à la
politique démocrate vis-à-vis de la
police que vous inspire ce type de
déclaration d'effets b-king des
soulèvements à philadephie et on a
également eu des manifestations de
soutien dans notre ville de minneapolis
slide l'attention et la solidarité se
développe au niveau national entre les
grandes villes
effectivement la plupart des grandes
villes américaines sont dirigées par des
élus démocrates mais cela ne semble pas
faire grande différence accepte tout à
fait la brutalité policière
cela fait cinq morts 5 - depuis la mort
de taureaux et il n'y a pas vraiment eu
de grands changements dans la police à
winnie abolissent la brutalité continue
à me laisse au minnesota
dix personnes supplémentaires sont
mortes depuis georges floyd à la suite
d'actions policières diverses
il s'agit du parti démocrate ou du parti
républicain le discours est très
différent mais les actions en tout cas
au niveau de la politique policière
montrent que l'objectif de la police est
de contrôler la population en fonction
notamment de la race d'empêcher les
mauvaises personnes de se retrouver dans
les mains les bons voisinages d'empêcher
certaines populations de se retrouver
dans les mauvais quartiers
cela fait partie intégrale du
fonctionnement de la police et les élus
vont accepter cela et à suivre les
consignes à des personnes qui ont
l'argent et le pouvoir mais nous sommes
bien plus nombreux c'est là notre force
avec la solidarité dans la rue et celle
qui permet d'aider les victimes de la
brutalité policière
c'est l'une des choses positives en 2020
de ce point de vue c'est très
encourageant que les manifestations
continuent et que le travail à vous en
coulisse continue également afin de
pousser au changement
merci beaucoup à des vikings d'avoir été
avec mon manque du conseil
d'administration des communautés unis
contre la brutalité policière merci à
vous en direct donc de minneapolis